flooding heat waves storms
increasingly extreme weather is forcing
cities to adapt to global warming or
face dire consequences around 56 of us
worldwide live in urban areas and by
2050 two-thirds of us are expected to
live in cities
here are four ways to climate-proof a
city
transport accounts for around 24 of the
world's emissions and cars contribute a
huge amount to that but even public
transport could be a greenhouse gas
village
back in london the rail network uses 1.2
terawatt hours of power each year that's
enough to power around 360
000 homes
but now the city's mayor is attempting a
huge green overhaul of london's
transport
we've got to make sure we continue to be
bold retrofitting our buildings even
more electric buses even more charging
points i want more and more of london
breathing cleaner
switching public transport to run on
green hydrogen or renewables and
encouraging residents to drastically cut
the number of cars on the roads is the
first step towards climate proofing your
city
[Music]
a third of all food produced globally is
wasted and the world's food system
produces around 25 to 30 percent of all
greenhouse gas emissions so cutting food
waste is a good second step
in italy the city of milan has developed
a system that deals with food waste and
also tackles food poverty the local
government takes food waste from shops
and redistributes it through the city to
those that need it
the scheme is scalable to any city in
the world and has been given one million
pounds of funding by the earthshot prize
to spread the idea
green spaces are a huge factor in
climate-proofing a city not only do they
help to reduce air pollution decrease
day-to-day heat and improve the mental
health of residents they can also help
protect against flooding singapore has
announced a plan worth 53 billion pounds
to deal with climate change and a big
part of that relies on green spaces
parks and gardens even small flower beds
can act as sponges in cities
rainwater hitting concrete will run off
and may quickly trigger flooding but
rainwater hitting grass or soil will
soak in reducing the risk
by increasing the number of green spaces
the damage from extreme rain and
flooding can be reduced
even the buildings around us are going
to have to change energy use in
buildings from homes to shops to offices
account for around 28
of the world's emissions
lots of countries now have requirements
for new sites to be built sustainably
but existing buildings are a huge
problem when the empire state building
was finished it was the tallest building
in the world and seen as an
architectural feat
now it has become a model for climate
innovation
32 million dollars have been spent
retrofitting it making it the largest
project of its kind in the us
everything from
6514 windows to its 73 elevators have
been optimized to increase energy
efficiency
the project has cut the building's
energy use by 40 percent and saved its
owners 4 million dollars a year in costs
from replacing gas boilers to shoring up
leaky walls retrofitting on a massive
scale is another step needed to make
many cities climate proof
if you think climate change is a long
way off think again
70 of cities are already dealing with
climate change
and over 90 percent of all urban areas
are coastal putting most cities on earth
at a risk of flooding from rising sea
levels and powerful storms essential to
stopping the worst effects is changing
the way and where we live
[Music]